[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to this video
on DevOps value stream mapping in this
video we will cover the following what
is value stream mapping that is VSM what
role does value stream mapping play in
DevOps how is value stream mapping being
implemented in DevOps and finally how
will value stream mapping useful before
we dig deep into value stream mapping
that is VSM let's ask the million dollar
question how does software change lives
software is transforming the priorities
of business in every industry consider
how Tesla has disrupted the automotive
industry how Airbnb has changed the
world of hotel bookings and vacation
rentals and how uber has turned the taxi
business upside down each of these
companies led with the software that
created an entirely new experience for
the customer now agile and DevOps
practices increase the speed of delivery
and the quality of the product there are
many ways that software changes the
industry for the better
organizations which use DevOps tools in
various stages of the software
development lifecycle you often find
themselves in a struggle to gather an
overall understanding of the lifecycle
right from planning to operations
feedback is also something that is
necessary to be collected at every step
of the process to constantly improve the
product the faster these feedbacks are
received the better will be the value of
the product created and this is the core
where value stream mapping brings value
to the DevOps lifecycle now that we have
understood why we need VSM let's find
out what it really is in today's market
organizations don't compete on the basis
of their product or service they provide
it is done on the basis of how fast it
is able to provide quality products and
results via SEM in general can be
defined as a representation of all the
steps followed by a product from its raw
material stage to its final product form
it is one of the important Lean
principles that organizations use Lean
principles usually ensure that the
is able to obtain more value and
eliminate waste while utilizing lesser
resources it graphically represents each
stage in the process from product
development to deployment
it helps recognize areas where value
isn't created and then ensures that
these are taken care of so now let's try
to understand what role V is some place
in DevOps the VSM process enables IT
organizations to identify areas for
improvement V ISM usually starts with
the product person or the team as
they're the direct line to the customer
now the process moves through the
development lifecycle QA testing release
and operations and how the IT team
monitors and manages this product or
feature after release now the value
stream doesn't end there
it looks down through deployment and up
at the customer to see if the project
achieves its goals it exposes wastes and
inaccuracy in the critical activities
involved in software development and
operations it helps identify the delays
the constraints and other issues that
may arise in the process it also
integrates multiple tools analyzes
events and provides accurate usable data
to the managers via some helps companies
realize the value that they are
receiving from DevOps tools now how will
we assume implemented in DevOps V ISM
involves creating a value stream map
which represents the current state of an
organization's software development and
operations this helps in realizing what
development needs to be done in an ideal
value stream map some of the key metrics
collected are percentage current or
accurate now for a given we a sub step
this is the percent of complete or
accurate work items receive from the
previous step in the VSM next one lead
time lead time for a given VSM step that
is from the instant work item leaves the
previous step to the instant it leaves
the current step towards the next step
lead time includes both idle time as
well as time during which the item is
being productively processed and last
value added value added time which is
the only time during which the item is
being productively processed a VSM based
on the previously created VSM helps
create an improved and realistic
representation of the activities without
the bottlenecks and issues that plagued
it in its current stage a VSM is
successful when an organization realizes
all its issues as quickly as possible to
move into a more efficient form now
let's understand how we SM is of use in
DevOps these metrics spanning the entire
DevOps lifecycle are of great use when
it comes to solving on line scaling
issues affecting the speed of delivery
guiding business decisions and reducing
operational costs all the way ISM
supports significantly in finding
bottlenecks and pain point it's not the
only thing it's useful for analyzing
value streams can greatly improve the
confidence of the department regarding
its choice of projects and ventures with
the data that can be obtained from the
key performance indicators which is the
value of how effectively a company is
achieving its business objectives and
the metrics across the tool chain
important business decisions can be
taken effortlessly with the data to back
it up via some allows greater visibility
from the time to value of the
development to the delivery lifecycle
significantly it helps in eliminating
the redundant processes faster
integrated feedback and expanding
successful strategies this also leads to
greater traceability helping trace
errors to their origins correcting
issues and better work quality each tool
in the DevOps tool chain
creates its own set of data and events
it's a matter of great importance that
the data is correlated and integrated
intelligently it allows DevOps users to
obtain an insight into
all the stages of the software lifecycle
it greatly increases the speed and
quality of the process from its
production to its delivery
thus value stream mapping provides a
framework on the basis of which
appropriate decisions and judgments can
be made regarding the right course of
action in the perspective of a business
the value stream mapping process doesn't
happen once and in there these are I
trade you and they need to be revisited
and read irregularly to understand
what's been accomplished hey once become
an expert in cloud computing then
subscribe to simpler Channel and click
here to watch more such videos turn it
up and get certified in cloud computing
click here